my name is Maggie Schmidt
I'm Catherine's mother and we live in
Medford Massachusetts hi captain my name
is Bruce Kulick we love Kathryn of
course and are very proud of her oh
she's a treating she's fun
she sometimes is a handful but now she's
getting out on her own and I'm sure
she'll do very well I don't take any
credit for where she ended up getting
because I think the innate nature of her
personality was that wherever she would
end up she would succeed but I think as
parents what we wanted to give her was
realizing that there are no limitations
on what you can accomplish and
especially as a mother of the daughter
that as a woman working or going to
school that you can do anything that you
set your mind to she was always very
active and acrobats and starch actually
later joined the gymnastics team when
she was in high school one of the joys
is we both enjoy bike riding a lot in
2012 we actually rolled from Boston to
San Francisco the trip that I'll never
forget in my lifetime nor will she
we had no expectation when she applied
to Harvard that well you know you may
get in your may not but it seemed like
it just was meant to be and I think
she's really learned so much and taking
advantage of the full range of offerings
so that's been great as a parent to see
that I wouldn't deny that I might shed
it's here seeing her getting her diploma
I haven't really thought much about that
but I'm the kind of guy that cries at
weddings so you know we'll see what
happens
she's grown as a woman as a student a
learner I think she can now go into the
working world and really make a
contribution so I'm just happy for her I
just it's no sadness it's all good
Catherine always do a good job and what
you do follow through on your
commitments to make sure you only make
commitments you can follow through on
sometimes it's okay to say no always
keep the positive attitude don't hold
yourself to standards that you feel you
have to meet but enjoy your life and
enjoy your activities and and just have
fun with your future and come back and
visit us sometime